steve nash 18-year veteran
hall of famer and now the new head coach
of the brooklyn nets and uh good chance
now to uh
to say hey coach how are you i'm doing
great
thanks ej hey so tell me how this all
went down and
how you surprised the basketball world
or how brooklyn did with this
announcement
how did this play out you talk to them
and say i'm interested
did did they talk to you and say hey
what do you think about this how did how
did it work
yeah i definitely reached out and and
showed my interest
and and asked to be considered um you
know sean marks and i the general
manager have had a relationship going
back 20 years we played against each
other internationally we played together
for the phoenix suns and against each
other
during our careers so we've had a
conversation for 20 years and friendship
and understanding
so i think there was history there
you know just happened to be the right
time i think i when i left
playing i needed time to decompress i
needed time to get away from the game i
was a pretty obsessive
person who who put everything he had
into his career and i needed some space
and kind of
find out who i was uh with a new
identity and not being able to rely on
that whole process that
we as professional athletes you know
lock ourselves into for so long
and once i got through that i started to
really
just observe uh ask questions continue
to be curious and inquisitive and and
prepare myself for
[Music]
the eventuality that one day i could
have an opportunity so
this opportunity was was i thought an
incredible fit for me
and i put my name in the hat well you
know steve number one congratulations uh
my question is we saw brooklyn play a
couple of weeks ago
and they're not great on paper so this
is a rebuilding job
how how quick do you think gonna have
this thing turned around
[Laughter]
as soon as two guys lace up their
sneakers were rebuilt
you know obviously i have to say though
i thought that what jack vaughn and the
players and staff did in the bubble was
outstanding you know
heavily undermanned uh there was a
connectivity and a spirit about them
they closed the season well found
themselves in the playoffs and
you know gave everything they had
against the terrific toronto team so
first of all maximum kind of respect for
what they did in the bubble
um but we we it's not a rebuilding year
we have high expectations
we compete to win but at the same time
this is a fresh situation because
we haven't had a full roster so i'm
excited by the roster a lot of talent
depth a lot of guys can put the ball on
the floor which is obviously pivotal as
you watch these playoffs and
unfold so it's going to be exciting and
we're going to build something that's
going to be a lot of fun a great
environment for the players and staff
and we're going to build together uh
steve obviously this is a new situation
for you what's going to be your style as
a coach
how are you going to control and
motivate two of the greatest players in
the world
are you a yeller or you're not a yeller
what's going to make you stand out as a
coach
i feel like they're going to play this
clip during that first time i go off
during the season but i don't see myself
as
a yeller you know i think you know i
want to be
a strong communicator i want to build
deep relationships with the players you
know i think that's number one you know
we can talk about x's and o's when
you're talking about great players
i think the number one thing no matter
you know if you're
a top team in league or in the bottom
half communication culture building
those relationships
trust line of communication those are
the things that go before
any x's and o so i think that's where a
lot of the work is going to be is trying
to develop
in-depth relationships trust line of
communication where there's
clear and simple understanding of
assignments and rules
and uh but that's the fun part you know
that's i think a place where i can excel
and add to this group steve you know he
talked about style of coaching but what
is your style of
play uh that you see that that the uh
brooklyn nets will play
if you if you had to mirror a team
that's
you know not mirror if you had to say a
team oh that's a similar style of what
we're going to be doing
is it closer to what d'antoni and you
guys have done in phoenix
is it closer to what you did with nelly
in dallas or is it somewhere different
you know it's probably somewhere
different in that the game's changed so
much
since then um you know i think it'd be
dangerous for me to try to fit this team
into my image or the image of one of the
teams i played on but i
definitely will be influenced by all the
coaches i had an opportunity to play for
nelly being a hall of famer
mike d'antoni obviously just had an
incredible career brilliant coach alvin
gentry danny ainge
you know so many coaches had an
influence on me i think though that this
is something we're going to build we're
going to want to play fast we're going
to want to make quick decisions
you know create opportunities to to
drive the ball to basket
draw and kick attack closeouts you know
i think offensively won't be our problem
i think the number one thing for us is
building a really solid defense
simple clear making sure that we
understand our roles and expectations
and building from there steve there's
certainly been
a lot of folks talking about this hire
and you hear white privilege
and you yourself said yeah i kind of
skipped the line here but what is your
uh what is your take on those who look
at
white privilege in a situation like this
as opposed to
hey 18 years in the league two-time mvp
with that kind of basketball pedigree
yeah first of all white privilege is
real
and it is something that exists and i
think as white people we have to accept
that we don't have to pay necessarily
for the the sins of you know of our
forefathers but
we can change and we can be a part of
change going forward so i think it's
important that we recognize that
um you know i don't think that's you
know or this situation
is white privilege personally you know i
think that my career
and there's precedence here uh that
speaks for itself you know there's
been other coaches that have jumped i
think first of all i think
you know jumping the line and and uh or
the q and and
white privilege are two different issues
but uh i think the wife
privilege argument isn't really
contextual to this situation because of
the career
the unique position i was in leading nba
teams for 18 years
uh the insight that i gathered from
being the head of teams
but you know it is something we do need
you know more african-american coaches
in all positions
not just in the coaching staff front
offices so that's something we have to
the fight to find a way to to get more
of these talented
you know ex-players or african-americans
coming up to the system
opportunities and a stairway and a
pathway to rise through the game um you
know the psy family the owner of
owners of the nets have pledged 50
million dollars and to look at
developing organizational and
you know things in the community that
will help fight racial injustice so
you know i feel really proud i feel like
an ally to the cause
i don't think this is a case of white
privilege
but i think white privilege is real so
steve i'm looking over here
on fanduel uh uh 25 games
uh your first technical over and under
uh your first uh ejection you know i
never
did the refs come on uh your over
on getting tossed for the first time is
30 games so can you give me some advice
before you get how long it's going to be
before you get your first technical
or your first ejection well we can we
can talk offline we can get that out of
the way
[Laughter]
call me
steve nash we congratulate you man and
uh
oh you got something you got something
uh if you're at your house can you show
me one of those mvp
trophies that you stole from me
congratulations
i mean i don't know if you can't make a
free throw down the stretch you know
it's
all ridiculous buddy
steve nash congratulations on uh the the
great opportunity you have now with the
uh
with the brooklyn nets always good
talking to you thank you congratulations
buddy
thanks fellas